lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
comparar las fracciones tres cuartos
y cuatro puntos
y quiero hacer esto de manera visual lo
que voy a hacer es tener dos copias del
mismo entero esto es un entero aquí voy
a resaltar todo el rectángulo que es mi
entero
y abajo de este tenemos el mismo entero
es un rectángulo del mismo tamaño y lo
voy a resaltar de este color naranja y
quizá ya se dieron cuenta que he
dividido cada entero con diferente
número de partes iguales el entero que
está arriba está dividido en cuatro
partes iguales ya que a mí aquí me están
interesando los cuartos por lo que este
entero lo estoy dividiendo en cuartas
partes y este entero de aquí abajo lo
dividí en quintas partes porque aquí me
interesan los quintos o lo que es lo
mismo en cinco partes iguales
ahora veamos lo que representan tres
cuartos este es uno de los cuartos
con una cuarta parte
dos cuartas partes
aquí tenemos tres cuartas partes y
cuando va a ser cuatro quintos veamos
aquí tengo el primer quinto dos quintos
y tres quintos
y cuatro quintos y recuerden que estamos
tomando fracciones del mismo entero
estos son tres cuartos de este
rectángulo y estos son cuatro quintos
del mismo rectángulo no tendría caso que
hiciéramos esto con formas diferentes o
con rectángulos de diferente tamaño y
aquí vemos claramente que estos cuatro
quintos son más grandes que los tres
cuartos
por lo que cuatro quintos es mayor que
tres cuartos como podemos decir que tres
cuartos es menor que cuatro quintos de
cualquier forma el símbolo que quieren
usar siempre se va a abrir hacia el
número más grande cuatro quintos cuatro
quintos es más grande que tres cuartos
por lo que este símbolo se abre hacia la
parte más grande que es cuatro quintos
por lo que decimos tres cuartos es menor
que cuatro quintos